the company premier FX collapsed a year
ago shocked customers claim they've been
abandoned by investigators businesswoman
Pauline Creasy lost nearly half a
million pounds she says there's a clear
case of fraud and I feel that there were
a lot of people that seem to be looking
the other way
as far as premier FX's conduct is
concerned and and that is a question
that should be investigated by the city
of London police and I and it should be
investigated of course by the FDA but
it's difficult because they're
effectively also investigating
themselves as to how they allowed this
to happen one after another the various
investigators the victims thought would
help said they couldn't help in Surrey
where the company was based police said
it would be too difficult and costly to
launch an investigation two months ago
the police Inspectorate said fraud
victims were not receiving the level of
service they deserve for some forces
fraud does not bang bleed or shout
everyone likes the site data protection
or it's nothing to do with them or it's
outside their remit outside their
responsibility and it is disgraceful and
appalling but what we have to have is a
national economic crime police force of
dedicated people who are expert at
finding money finding forces the company
was regulated by the UK's financial
conduct authority but only to transfer
customers money many expats were
persuaded to deposit money with the firm
but it wasn't authorized to hold their
cash premiers founder Peter X true was
the sole director when he died suddenly
in Lisbon last year his son Charlie and
daughter Katie took over as directors
but soon closed the firm Katie told Sky
News she had no idea what happened to
the missing money
two years ago premier FX was find here
in Portugal for operating unregulated
the UK's financial conduct authority was
told about that but it took no action
the FCA went on to renew
years license months before it collapsed
retired Major Bill Bullock lost more
than a quarter of a million pounds he
blames the FCA amazes me that as laters
I think it was May 2018 they reregulate
'add premier FX and without looking into
exactly what was going on in the company
the FCA's chief executive told mps he
believes the company had been acting
illegally the principle involved in this
activity is said to be dead I think it
is incumbent upon his relatives his
business partners to tell us where the
money is in Portugal Peter extras home
stood empty and neglected as Liquidators
searched for his company's assets Marty
branch sky news on the Algarve coast